shattered windows
damaged wall panels
the aftermath of a russian airstrike at
kharkiv institute of physics and
technology
it's ukraine's largest and oldest
nuclear science research center
from the russian side several shelves
have been fired towards the territory of
the institute thank god the main
installation remained intact but there's
quite a lot of damage around the
institute
this is a research center not a nuclear
plant but spent radioactive fuel is
stored here and that needs to be
protected
despite the fact that in working
condition the installation does not pose
any threat if the physical damage of
this installation takes place
it's possible that the fuel and
radioactive elements would leak and of
course it would be a big big problem for
the environment
ukraine's nuclear sites have been caught
up in the fighting russian troops are
now in charge of chernobyl the site of
the world's worst nuclear accident and
there was shelling at europe's biggest
nuclear power station a fire erupting at
a training facility that burned for
hours
the world's nuclear watchdog says it has
to move fast to ensure that a nuclear
incident doesn't become an unintended
consequence of this war
leah harding al jazeera